[Music]
[Applause]
john smoltz hall of famer
major league baseball network analyst
before i talk baseball with you john
here's the question
i'll give you two pga championships
or one masters
wow um masters
three pga championships one masters
three pga championships yeah
a world series ring or the masters
well i got a world series ring
so i'm gonna say the masters
what could be another like you didn't
really do much in the world series to
win
where right you were just on the team
you were on a great
team yeah yeah so let's say
i get the winning i get pitch game seven
win another ring
yes taking it yeah yeah world series mvp
or the masters
world series mvp that's just another
ring
all right that's all i wanted to talk to
you about john thanks for joining us
that was so easy uh clayton kershaw came
out and said all these no-hitters not
good for baseball
what does he mean by that do you think
i'm not quite sure i i think i would
follow him in the sense that
you know um when you see the statistics
on everyone keeps talking about the
statistics right batting average
strikeouts all those things uh
you you start you start understanding
that you know hitting has been hard with
the velocity that we have in our game
today so
maybe that's part of what he meant i on
the other hand predicted that the no
hitter record
on mlb network first week of the season
i predicted there would be a record
amount of no hitters so
hey i'm all about being right so two
more
i need two more paulie can you check the
tape see if smolt said this we looked
for it all morning we finally
find it yeah oh it's on there oh it's on
there
it was a bold prediction it was one of
these segments to make a bold prediction
and i made a bold prediction that there
would be more than eight no hitters this
year
okay but what's the cause for this all
these no-hitters other than everybody's
throwing 100 and everybody else who's at
the plate is trying to hit a home run
yeah well the latter part is what you
really uh have to focus on because i
think most of the no hitters you know
are not guys that have thrown 100 and
they're they're they're guys that have
hit their spots
and kind of open up the uh
opportunity if you hit your spots you're
gonna get your strikeouts and
outs and the style of hitting today
because the velocity is the way it is
it's really a philosophy of style of
hitting and when you're trying to hit a
home run which is the fastest way to get
a point on the board
then you don't have any deviation from
that i think that's why you're seeing
some of the numbers historically change
and i think we've all said that
eventually it'll come around it's just
taking a long time for the pendle
pendulum to swing back you're going to
have the lowest aggregate batting
average
in history this year um
baseball talked about the initiative
this year of maybe reducing
you know the uh uh i guess
how far baseball can be hit they were
trying to bring it back one or two feet
they were trying to get the ball and
play a little bit more stolen bases
those kind of things
uh it hasn't worked how does baseball
if that's what their goal is get more
involvement more movement in the game
i think part of it you know after we get
through this year and then you know next
year gets worked out
one way or another between the agreement
i think you're going to see some changes
that take place in the game they're
starting some things in the minor league
and whenever people talk about changes
immediately everyone says well there's
something
vehemently wrong with the game well to
your point you're stating the facts
and when you state the facts that
overwhelmingly
are historically not in your favor then
you look to make some changes
to try to enhance or change the way
people think see
the only way you can change the way
people think is to come up with some
rule changes every other sport has done
it for some reason baseball
people get all bent out of shape when we
talk about changes i'll give you a
subtle change that not a lot of people
talk about i've heard some people talk
about but i think would help the game in
both ways
if you lower the strike zone you give
the hitters a better chance at the
velocity that we're seeing today
to hit a ball that is at the top of the
strike zone you can't hit it today
and all pitchers are adjusting and
hitters are still
still trying to do what we talked about
the top of the zone is
at the velocity we have it it's just too
difficult so a subtle change
without making everybody have to change
the way they play the game
i'm a big big component of lowering the
strike zone and giving everybody a
better chance to hit that kind of
velocity that's in the game today he's
john smoltz mlb network analyst padres
tonight
against the mariners at 10 eastern then
john will call the cubs cardinals
tomorrow
on fox uh let's recap what happened with
the white sox with tony larussa
jermeen mercedes a rookie who tony says
i yelled take take take on a 3-0 pitch
in uh a blowout game he swung 3-0 hit a
home run
um let's go step by step so 3-0 pitch
positional player in a blowout game what
is the policy
yeah see that's a great question because
we haven't seen as many position players
pitched in the history of the game as
we're seeing right now so
if there's a regular around the mound i
think every player understands the score
time and place that that is just
something it's not that you can't do it
it's just frowned upon you know if
you're taking advantage of a team it's
like scoring
from you know from first uh when you're
up 15 to four when you can go station to
station
and i think there's certain things in
the game everyone understands when a
position player is on the mount i think
it kind of alters
how i can see the other side of it right
3-0
kind of frowned upon position player
well
that team's basically given up and so
it's kind of difficult when you see the
position player out there
to think that all the rules apply so
this is one of those scenarios where i
could actually see both sides of it i
understand tony larussa
being a manager as long as he has he
doesn't want
to show anybody up in that fashion
and that's probably where he's coming
from there yeah but okay so then can i
swing at 3-1 can i swing it 3-2
like yeah no i i get where you're going
i i think don't put yourself in that
situation
if you're the other team i totally get
it and if you're if you're basically
waving the right white flag by throwing
a position player then i don't think you
can get mad
that guys are swinging at pitches when
the pitchers that are coming in aren't
really pitches anyways
they're just somebody lobbing it in
there so i totally get that that part of
it
um you know we used to have that rule
where you had to have designated they
did away with that this year and i think
it's coming back by the way
where you had to designate only a
particular person that could pitch you
had to have so many innings
because that that to me is a whole other
subject when you start throwing position
players in the game you should start
advocating for the 10-run rule
uh that people i know have been floating
out there why not just get a 10-run rule
after seven innings we don't have to
have a position player out there
pitching do you think that baseball
would push for
a mercy rule after seven innings
i think if the trends keep going the way
they are i think it has more momentum
than it doesn't because the reality of
the game that we're playing
and we're supposed to be in the pitching
rich era you know there's
injuries there's a lot of pitchers up in
the big leagues probably faster than
they should
and so therefore clubs aren't are
they're not going to push their pitchers
and they're going to throw a position
player
i think it'd be better if we just the
game i mean the game's changed to a
seven inning
double header nobody frowns over that
anymore what no one would frown over a
ten run rule
after seven innings and each clubs go
about their way and then the headlines
don't read about
a position player pitching instead of
the team getting beat
well and and tony larussa says hey you
know what you got to respect the game
i don't think the opposition's
respecting the game by bringing in a
positional player to throw a 47.
if i can throw a fastball faster than
the position player
right now that to me is disrespecting
the game
i agree with you on that i played for a
manager who was old school
bobby cox never let a position player
ever pitched and the entire time i was
there
i don't know if there's another manager
that can say that but he never let
that was his biggest thing about i'm not
going to disrespect the game and make it
look foolish
now there were a lot of position players
that beg to pitch but he just didn't he
just didn't believe in it so
i i i agree with you 100 on that that
that statement because i think there is
unless you've
run out you've pitched eight you play 17
or 18 innings which we won't do anymore
because of the rule
then i think you know you're just you're
throwing everything up and
you're just throwing everything up in
the air so i agree with your statement
yeah and i don't and i don't like i
think everybody was wrong in this
situation with
you know mercedes and larussa okay
he he didn't uh hear the take sign or
didn't listen to your take sign then he
homers
tony then calls him out in the press
conference instead of
supporting his player to say we'll
handle it inside he's basically saying
hey minnesota twins go ahead throw at
him
those are the consequences that he
brought on himself here
yeah you know this was a lot of mixed
messages but i think the general theme
that i was reading into it was
we can't have that happen again right
what right wrong or indifferent
and and hopefully uh that that message
was clear to the team
the white sox are a great team yeah and
the minnesota twins are having a really
tough year
they were they were predicted to be
right there with the chicago white sox
you can understand their frustration
when they're getting it handed to them
but again when you
when you throw a position player in
there it does throw a wrench
in the whole deal and again some people
think it's kind of
fun to watch a position player pitch i
personally don't think it's fun
as much as the amount of position
players that are pitching
today is pretty alarming how surprised
were you that uh pujols
goes to the dodgers and hit a home run
last night
i'm not home run absolutely because of
where
pools is in his career i i have the
utmost respect for him
because of his passion to play the game
and yet
yes he's not the pujols that we remember
with saint louis and even
the angels but i think his motor still
thinks he can help a team
win a championship and what better way
for him he went to a team that has the
probably the best odds to win a
championship
and i think he's going to prove some
people wrong um
you know this game is not forever and we
all know that
everybody including myself have been
released
it's not fun but you want to finish on
your own terms and i think that's what
he's doing
did poo holes get you he got me a lot
it was only eight of bats he got me
three times three home runs
and eight at bats and i don't i don't
mind telling you it was the scariest
right-hander hitter i've ever faced i
thought gary sheffield was number one in
my book
but albert pujols the way he squatted to
sit he looked like he was sitting in a
rocking chair knew what was coming
and i'll never forget the game i came
out of the bullpen in relief
and i was so mad because of the
circumstances that led me getting in i
threw a pitch for the first time my
career as hard as i could
it almost went to big big mac land and
i tried to i tried to destroy the the
there were these the curtain that
separated the training room and the
clubhouse in the old stadium
and they looked like you could rip them
off the hinge so i attacked it with both
of my hands to rip it off
it was steel reinforced and i thought i
broke both my thumbs
and i hid in the back of the plane icing
both of my thumbs
not letting anybody see what had
happened so yeah he got me okay
peak peak poo holes peak bonds
wow um yeah that that to me
i always i'm gonna say pujol speak
because i feel as a right-handed pitcher
i should always be able to have the edge
against a right-handed hitter
left-handers definitely had an edge
against me so i'm still gonna say pools
only because i
felt like i should have done better
bonds i faced for a hundred times
pools i don't want to even think about
what that three
what that would have translated i gave
up nine home runs to bonds i'm sure i
would have given up more to pools
great to talk to you john thanks for
joining us as always buddy
pleasure thanks that's uh john smoltz uh
we share a birthday together
may 15. uh he's got cubs cardinals
tomorrow
on fox